hello Mac come back the game sports
coverage of pax 2014 we are live from
sector June thank you I didn't I didn't
let's try that again we're live from
sector G I'm delighted to be joined by
Dustin broader hey do and serve for
blizzard you guys are showing off heroes
of the storm we are I'm not wait to see
this game they are queuing up in their
droves waiting for years to play right
yes I guess yeah actually you guys have
a pretty decent IQ at the blizzard booth
we do we're doing but we have a lot of
people come to see us and it's always
exciting to talk to a lot of our fans
and sort of see what they want to see
about the games and it's just a great
time to be here at pax I'm able to
interact I'm with all the players yes
you guys are in you've got a sort of a
very restrictive alpha at the moment
there's not too many people and it's not
too many people at what are you showing
off here at the moment is it that same
build it's it's a very similar bill
we've got some stuff that's unique here
to the show today we've got a new Barrak
we've got Chen we've got a bday on these
are three new heroes to heroes of the
storm a couple of tanks and a specialist
they're all sort of rolling in some of
them are a little bit wackier than the
others Chen for example is this you know
penderrin brewmaster and he has a very
special resource mechanic where he will
stop and drink from his keg to refill
his energy and we sort of tuned him so
you're really encouraged to do that in
the middle of the fight so the big
battle raging hey time for a drink and
Chen will drop and grab his you know
barrel and just start chowing down right
in the middle of a battle sec it
appreciates it's a pretty fun character
to play and we're looking at the
character select screen here and its
particulars chain right there generate
there and Arthas you've got like
basically it's just is it Warcraft
starts all of them all roll together any
lost vikings in there yeah no yeah no
yeah and hang on stay tuned that's
that's something we'd love to do Sarah
too of course that what stage you have
to stop putting in characters because i
like the blizzard lower is full of well
the lore won't be the problem right the
only time we'd stop putting in
characters to feel like we've gone up
there's King's life is literally about
to say is stitches in here oh absolutely
absolutely so we really want to go for
as long as we can once we think we're
repeating ourselves maybe at that point
we'll go enough we've got enough here is
we want each co2 feel like his own
his or her own unique gameplay
experience we've got heroes that are a
little bit more traditional if you care
like a ball of the demon hunter who's
just sort of staying in Lane she's got a
bunch of abilities balls she can spray
her arrows she can do a hungry arrow
abilities you might see in Diablo sort
of firing away at the same time I got
characters like Abba thur this is a in
fester character from Starcraft 2 who
will in festus a lie so I was a can't
fight can't bite at all he'll hide in
the base and then he'll infest his
allied heroes on the map and then you're
firing skill shots from your allies I'm
cool think it's hard to hit a skill-shot
when you're doing it yeah majan you
can't control your own feet and now
you're trying to fire skill shots as you
run around the battlefield so this is a
character that's jumping from hero to
hero all over the place all over the map
it's a very difficult character to play
a very challenging hero this is also a
hero that can when he gets to his
ultimate ability he can actually copy
one of his allies and then you become
that hero for a little while so you have
to know a lot of the heroes in the game
to play a bethere because when you clone
somebody you you've got to know right
away what they're capable of them what
they can do and so for anyone watching
this who maybe hasn't had any experience
with it dad obviously the comparisons to
dota and mobile why not you guys been
pretty vocal about calling this a hero
brawler door what is it about this game
do you think actually makes it stand out
from well we're going with big packet
totally we're going with 20-minute games
or thereabouts-- that can go longer but
they generally don't so a much shorter
gameplay experience we're really
balancing the game around the team fight
so it's like getting together with your
friends you will have laning phases like
this space here where stitches and
Sergeant hammer here are battling
against a couple of players against
tutorial and Tychus but rather rapidly
on a lot of our maps you'll be asked to
come together as a five-man team and
fight and then you'll be spread out
again you come back together again for
the big fight so we're really getting
you together as a team we're also doing
a lot of unique things like team levels
you notice at the top of the screen
there's two number twos those are the
levels of both teams you don't level
individually you level as a team because
you're coming together as a team to
fight against the enemies so that no
point should you worry about taking from
your allies you should never worry that
I don't want to kill an enemy player
because somebody else is supposed to get
that kill so they can get experienced it
is i mean like last hit mechanics no
last hit McCann okay Hugo you seen enemy
you kill him that's your job right don't
worry about it it also allows us to do
things like this right now stitches is
off in the middle of the jungle right
now fighting against these creeps he's
going to
other seeds that allow his team to get
access to a giant plant monster later in
the game well there's not a lot of
experience being earned out here right
now but that's okay because we have team
level somebody else could be making sure
we're still farming in Lane we're still
gaining an advantage this is this crazy
battle going to happen around this giant
plant golem all stitches tries to pick
up the seeds tries to dodge the attacks
of the plant gone Wow kerrigan kuranda
and tigers come in and engage in this
fight and this is the story the human
battles that happen it's almost
impossible to know what the next move is
sometimes you're dodging sometimes
you're grabbing seeds sometimes you're
attacking enemies here comes a hook whoa
there's the big hook unter onda pulling
on a position that looks like they're
going to take her down but just a lot of
chaos really asking to stretch yourself
as a player to deal with the unexpected
and that's the point of having multiple
battlegrounds we got five different
battlegrounds in the game right now so
you never know exactly what you're going
to see how much the variety is within
those vile games pretty significant so
this is a map right now we trying to
collect seeds we have other maps where
you're really just trying to add the
seeds are spawned from creatures on the
map we've other battlegrounds we're
trying to collect coins and get them to
an evil undead pirate Lord and then he's
going to turn the canons of his
battleship on the enemy of other maps
where they're going deep underground to
collect skulls there's always something
for you to do on the map that's going to
pull you together as a team or some
splits you up as a team and it really
depends on the map what the mechanics
are if you see like we're not even in
Lane we haven't been in Lane here four
minutes but critical things are
happening here the game is being won or
lost in these battles around these
gallons and this is what makes it sort
of unique yeah so obviously the team
nothing sort of takes away a lot of the
individual progression stuff what a
minute economy within the game there's
no last hit there's no gold and leveling
us all shared now you do have the way to
customize your here we think that is
important so we have instead of a
generic shop that applies to all heroes
we have a custom talent set per hero and
that allows us to do some really extreme
thing so for example when we were
developing the game we did have an item
shop that apply to everybody and that
seemed pretty cool to us and we had
ideas for items like we have an idea for
a plus range item would that be awesome
if some of our tanks be a little bit of
range so maybe instead of having a range
of one they have a range of three so now
they can kind of reach out a little bit
and touch somebody's but then if like a
hero like nova or valla the demon ER got
ahold of a plus three range on yeah the
game was broken so we'd go to the
balance because we will do a plush range
I'm like you can have +1 maybe plus
one-half you can
have this right that's what you get and
then but that was completely
uninteresting but then we started
splitting it out to a customized set of
talents / hero something we could go
nuts you see here that Phil who's
demoing this game first and one of our
artists has gotten the hold of the plant
horror there and he's charging across
the map you just turned to sergeant
hammer into little plant monster there
and he's attacking this town so this is
a very powerful siege weapon it's a
vehicle that he's in some of our Maps
have vehicles like this where you can
become these creatures that allow you to
store them in some of them don't it's a
whole different mechanics so I have you
guys don't have as many heroes to some
of the other games within it we're 28
right now 20 so is that a way of sort of
creating more variety there as well any
customization system is just can be good
for us at this point we're going to add
any more heroes 28 for a rat in the
Alpha we've got you know more we're
adding all the time we're just showing
three new ones here today and we'll keep
adding cheers as we go and I don't know
when we'll stop I don't know is it 50 is
it 100 is it 30 I don't know when we
start repeating actually I have more
than 30 built in the office or wait so
it's more than 30 but when we get more
we'll see when we sort of run out of
ideas again when we start repeating
ourselves I'm sure the Commission are
you feeling the same then maybe will
reconsider how many more we want to do
I'm sure the community will jump in and
give you a couple of suggestions Oh
totally we've had a lot of great ideas
already Vikings I hear you I hear you
all three of them I'm on board walking
along we'll work on it I like it alright
make it happen and what about other sort
of game modes you're talking about this
is when this particularly is collecting
the seeds and stuff Oh were the other
type of game well another one would be
you know on a map that you can be the
not really modes when you go into the
matchmaker you're gonna give these maps
so you don't know all right so you had a
beat for a flexible and creative and how
you engage with the game we are going to
be adding a you know a draft mode in the
future where you will actually see the
map before you launch so you can choose
you here because some heroes do a little
bit better on some maps and others
that's another great way to keep the
metagame fresh and keep it constantly
changing as we introduce battlegrounds
it's going to change the talents you're
going to want to choose it's going to
change your team compositions a little
bit keeps the game kind of going but so
this is yeah this is you know the one of
our one of our battlegrounds another one
that's one of my favorites is dragon
shire this is a map we have to control
the two shrines of the map is one and
near the top and one near the bottom if
you control both shrines simultaneously
it unlocks the dragon knight in the
middle of the map now if one of your
heroes can get to that dragon knight and
channel on that dragon that you will be
the dragon that was a giant engine of
destruction that can charge across the
map breathing fire he's got this huge
acts he can smack things with he can
kick other players and pump them halfway
across the map to kick them out of a
teamfight he's LP he's very powerful
don't get to be him like a minute right
got a very short period of time and of
course you mean to go to control really
all three lanes at least for a second or
two so it really causes players to split
up to deal with all three lanes and then
they come together around the Dragon
Knight to do their big push so it
creates a lot of teamwork and a lot of
strategy as opposed to a map like
cursive hollow this raven lord who rules
over this sort of strange dimension of
curse at hollow is spawning these
tributes and he's sort of asking you
you'll gather tributes for me and I will
curse your enemies and he's very much
sort of Mad Hatter kind of characters in
control of this evil dimension that you
come to and and so this is pulling into
these team fights around these tributes
frequently throughout the game very
different experience about a minute and
a half tributes going to spawn it's like
the ringing of the dinner bell all
players to the tribute everybody on your
mount go go go get to that tribute time
for the team fight everything is decided
here for at least the next few minutes
so it's a very different style of play
and perhaps one of the biggest
criticisms loaded on games like dota a
[ __ ] legends for is vastly popular and
fun as they are very cool games very
cool is that there's quite a barrier to
entry on the North Blizzard have kind of
got a history of doing right by that
like games like World of Warcraft right
first MMO really just a lot
accessibility is a big value or I think
we want to be very easy to learn but
still crazy hard to master so the games
always look very simple when you walk in
the door and then hopefully a hundred
hours later you're still learning
something new about the game that's
absolutely our goal so we have extensive
tutorial systems we're doing news or
testing on that all the time to see how
that's working for us we've got some
pretty good box in the game so you can
play cooperatively with my friends or
alone you want to get a feel for a hero
ok so there's also totally we've gotta
try me mode as well in each of the
heroes if you see it here you like the
look up you can just hit the try me mode
button and immediately you're in a very
small map where you can sort of choose
what level you want to be and sort of
say do I want minions no minions so I
want to hero to spawn do I not want to
hear to spawn so you can just sort of
test the water sort of a very basic sort
of arena you can kind of set up and
customize as much as you want so you get
a feeling of how this hero is going to
play you can test some of the ultimate
abilities you can test all the talents
so even if you
ready for a cooperative game yet you can
try the hero and see if it feels cool to
you see if it matches a play style that
makes sense to you another thing as well
perhaps mostly in world of warcraft was
the ability that you guys had to well I
know you invested quite a lot him to
making sure that the community was
moderated properly sure that people felt
like they were invited into the coding
world and that's another sort of a
problem he gave it a lot of these games
where this is quite a caustic
environment sure at least if when you
were sure when I saw it stars challenge
right absolutely huge challenge so we're
attacking it at a basic level first with
the game mechanics again no last hit
reduces the mean things I can do to you
that would make you upset I'm not kill
stealing it doesn't matter which means
again you're not going to get angry it's
a lot of the problems with diablo team
software they had Luke / hero yeah there
was never a scenario where i was going
to pick up your loot it was always going
to be milan if I saw it grab it it's on
the ground it's for you and so we're
trying to the same kind of thing from
the basic level 20 minute games also
help us with this enormously you're not
trapped in a game with somebody for 40
minutes or an hour and if he's playing
not to your standard yeah right you're
not gonna be quite as annoyed because
hey it's cool maybe maybe we can get
through this and maybe we have a chance
to win and also by making sure that the
levels remain relatively similar we do
have what we call an underdog bonus so
if you're behind in levels and you kill
an enemy players higher level than you
that's worth more as it should be
because he was higher level if I'm
higher level than you and I kill you
that's worth less because that makes
sense my [ __ ] spiritum RPG kind of system
so the levels we try to keep them as
close as we can without making you feel
like what you do doesn't matter Yeah
right so a level up or two levels up is
significant we try to keep them as close
as possible to be in a place where
you've always got a chance it's not
really over until it's over in the very
last minute for the most part we've been
successful which again reduces the
general toss the city because you don't
feel like you're trapped in a game where
you're doomed I guess the counter
pointed out is when you make games more
accessible and you start like sort of
trying to even off scale is that what
it's about well that's that number it's
not accessible versus hard to play it's
it's it's it's or which music cells were
hard to play it's not accessible versus
deep you can be accessible in deep for
me at least and maybe others would
disagree i feellike harsh tone shows
this very well the game is very
accessible at the same time I'm still
learning things about that game
200 hours later I'm I'm counting cards
I'm learning the metagame I'm able to
look and see what this kind of deck is
it oh it's a miracle rogue okay here's
how i play my warrior differently
because I'm playing just a miracle rogue
that's that's a pretty high level play
for me and I've gotten to that very
deliberative coming in a very accessible
game so we want the game to be
accessible but if you go up against the
top players and heroes right now you
will lose they are better because there
is a very strong skill component about
this game a very strong and powerful way
to work as a team to understand the map
mechanics to know when to work together
sure you're losing you know last hit but
you're gaining all of these different
map mechanics from the battlegrounds the
necessary to interact with the
mercenaries and all of the combos that
exist between all of these different
talents and all these different
different heroes coming together it
seems like you're really it seems like
you're trying to sort of get the best of
both worlds where you're making game
that's has that accessibility factor
like how important is eSports to you
though in that respect well for us it's
always a value to let our community
whatever they want with the game yeah so
we are allowing our players gonna do all
the same things we did for starcraft
when we launched starcraft we didn't
know if that was giving each sport that
was not a done deal we would go out you
know when we go out out there we would
say well we're gonna make this game but
it's probably there's no eSports was not
that big here in the United States I'm
in Europe obviously Korea was huge at
the time probably not gonna be a big
deal but we did everything we could to
support it we made sure we had a great
replay system a great observer mode that
the game was clean that read well if the
art was clear and the whole team rallied
around those values because they're not
good just for eSports they're also good
for game they make a good game so we do
the same thing here we're going to build
all the systems we can and we're going
to give this game to our players and
just like we do a starcraft we're going
to see what they do with it you know do
they want to make it into an eSport do
they not that's going to be up to them
and then if it starts to happen we'll
watch and see and do the best we can to
support that environment it's worked
very well for us in starcraft two make a
very healthy very community-focused
ecosystem and that's sort of our
strategy for heroes as well some of your
communities here of course it packs
you've got your booth inside I know that
there's an alpha that's currently
running it's a it's it's the only couple
thousand people and very very small
alpha right now and when you guys can
open this up for wider alpha or beta as
soon as we possibly can we're working on
the technology right now and working
very hard on our server infrastructure
to make sure that that is ready for a
large influx of players we're working on
Barry
limited hardware right now and when
we're ready when we're sure that we're
not going to do any damage out there and
not be crashing all the time are not
causing problems in our other games we
will obviously get it out there get it
into you know a closed beta and then an
open bed and get as many players in as
soon as we possibly can cool doesn't
blow from blazer thank you so much for
coming sir I'm at best of luck enjoy
dress the packs